who would be better at it
i think we would be good at different
things like
there we yeah typically
pokey ninja how's it going great to meet
you guys
good how are you i'm doing fantastic i
this is a pleasure for me because i am a
huge fan
of both of you pokey i've been sub to
your coach for like such a long time
thank you ninja i might be a little bit
you guys are big inspirations to me
being a youtuber myself this is just
super awesome
that you were guys or in this movie it
brought me more into the movie i
i love it more because of you guys so
thanks super cool to see you guys here
thank you to like the gamers so to be in
like the gaming movie
just like super cool how is it different
than streaming when you're entertaining
people on stream
whereas you're acting in the movie what
was that like pokey we can start with
you
honestly it was kind of nice to be able
to
take a second take on something usually
when you're streaming
you gotta say it right the first time or
um it might be clipped out of context
you might be in some trouble
so being able to deliver a few takes and
allow the editors to pick the best one
or to make you look and sound the way
that you want to
is really really nice having a little
bit of freedom and leeway there so
very enjoyable experience awesome ninja
absolutely the same uh it's it's always
nice to be able to be like oh [ __ ]
yeah can we get a can one more second
my favorite is where they're like just
keep going like there's sometimes where
like i'll mess up like i'll instantly
mess up the first line and they're just
like and i'll be like
dang it and they're like like we're
still rolling and then i just have to
like take two seconds you know
and then start again and like i actually
love that a lot it's my favorite way to
film
is is not like constantly being like is
cutting after every take or cutting
every time you mess up
like when they're just like you just
keep going dude like we're rolling we'll
edit that out and we'll make it like you
know i love that so it was um
just the way that we filmed it was
fantastic that's awesome and like
pokey like you said that's that's gotta
take a lot of the pressure off like
you're saying ninja just being able to
just keep going doing it over and over
again
whereas like you said on stream it's
like uh one and done
one done right yeah wow okay so
you're both in a movie with ryan
reynolds ninja you teased
on fallon like two years ago or
something that you were going to be in a
movie
uh more acting from both of you
coming this way or no is that you want
to pursue this
uh acting absolutely i do for sure i
already have like three
or four things that are coming like
they're already like
yeah i've done it i filmed it it's gone
it's just waiting for it to come out
um no like big crazy like movies or
anything like that but like a little
camo here
a part here so it's pretty exciting yeah
uh you're gonna be in the deputy yeah
i've never really seen myself as much of
an
actress but happy to do all the cameos
as myself
that you'd like or in kind of gaming
related movies i feel like that's more
you know
my niche or my area of expertise as well
well i mean you both did an incredible
job and again like it brought me
thank you it brought me like i feel more
for the movie because you guys have such
a big community
whereas if it was like brad pitt i love
brad pitt but you know he doesn't have
like an active online community like you
guys to
do you know youtube twitch twitter
everything
so it brought me more into it and it was
just really great to see you both there
i have a question
if if the game was real who would be
better at it
i think we would be good at different
things like
yeah typically when we when uh
you know when you play an mmo or a gta
style kind of
game for me i like to do a lot more like
selling and buying and trading and you
know talking to people
and organizing networks and stuff like
that maybe ninja would be more of just
like
getting high scores as many kills as you
can
i am current i am currently manipulating
the the market of an mmo that i'm
playing right now
oh it's a little intense
it's it's a lot of fun yeah what pokey
said
well you got to watch out if you play
among this with her because you never
know
i don't even i
listen you know it's part of the game
right so i mean really what was this
experience
like was it surreal i mean ninja you
said you want to pursue this some more
poke said you're open to it
is i mean what was it like as someone
who started
you know as a streamer who got famous of
streaming and became these social media
influencers and now in movies
what's that like so many people look up
to y'all
yeah man it's uh i mean obviously a
little pressure like you know don't mess
up
um but it's not that much pressure as
well because it's like
a sense of messing up because like if
you're a good person if you're if you're
a good person that you won't have a
problem
um so it's i guess it's just a little
taxing when you just have
i mean because every time you grow and
you do more you're just getting a bigger
audience and that's even more of like uh
you know like more work right and it's
like you're
supposed to work less but
stuff but somehow like they're just ends
up being the other way around
more like it's like even if you're not
streaming even if you're not streaming
as much like now you're doing more work
in the back end now you're doing more
more calls and like the busy stuff
yeah but this opportunity specifically
has been quite surreal
i really would have never expected
something like that if you were to tell
me
six years ago when i was studying
chemical engineering that i'd have an
opportunity to be in a movie i would not
have believed you
so yeah really happy i got to do it i
feel like it's like
cherry on top of my career where i'm at
so it's huge and congratulations thank
you
you were awesome on my youtube channel i
always end all my videos by saying my
little catchphrase it's woof woof i was
wondering if i could get a woof woof
from both of you before we go
dude perfect thank you
so much inspirations to me
i'll see you guys bye